E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e
registrando o momento presente
e pronto
é
conectado
assim a todos diariamente capitando
vendo interagindo olhamos o mundo
através dessas interfaces
vivendo um momento presente o tempo
desta foto é o tempo do presente Como
será o futuro desse presente
o que pode estar aqui partilhar a
respeito de memórias visuais e uma
pequena Obsessão não tão pequena assim
uma obsessão pessoal com o aniversário
de 150 anos da nossa cidade que começou
numa madrugada de outubro de dois mil e
nove quando dois versos vive eram no
pensamento de uma maneira muito forte
da minha cidade me desgosto me perdi na
identidade dela é porque eu desgosto
negócio é este de identidade
Nós já vamos chegar lá fora nem
aniversário estão faltando
1825 dias
24 horas 15 a 23 horas 26 minutos e 25
segundos para comemorarmos o aniversário
de 150 anos do início da colonização de
nossa região e fazermos aquela festa de
aniversário
o papa agora já não sou mais 15 minutos
e 10:26 vocês estão vendo como segundos
passam rápido o presente é isso passa
tão rápido como esse marcador de
segundos quando vemos sobra o tempo
passado e o caminho do Futuro Isso mesmo
o presente é um instante uma mistura de
passado com o futuro uma convenção
estamos sempre vivendo entre o que
aconteceu e o que está por acontecer
estamos sempre produzindo memórias
As
Memórias com esta que me vem à mente da
frente da loja do meu avô
bom e que começam com as nossas
histórias pessoais
esta foto me lembra quando eu tinha 8
anos
e aqui na Marechal na frente da loja meu
avô tendo o primeiro contato com a
poesia trem de ferro do Manuel Bandeira
[Aplausos]
o café com pão café completo
Oi cunhado hoje
percebo como esta poesia marcou a minha
trajetória
aqui está o meu avô materno ainda jovem
que veio da Alemanha com a sua família
no início do século passado
o
olhar com carinho nossas recordações
histórias pessoais nos remetem De onde
viemos
desperta nossa ancestralidade
e aqui temos algumas paisagens da época
da nossa região
o outro Imigrante alemã desta época
Teresa estude ser escritora e carta
Saudosa para sua irmã na Alemanha
definiu muito bem a ideia do presente
e dizendo o que na Alemanha se vive do
passado para o futuro aqui se vive o
presente Porque o país ainda não tem um
passado e ninguém precisa se preocupar
com o futuro
e nas pedras te conto Stories as velhas
árvores sussurro lends já quase
esquecidas a poesia que envolve sem que
percebas e aqui a todos os imigrantes
colonizadores estavam sempre voltados
para a vida do tempo presente na luta
pela sobrevivência e não é muito
diferente nos nossos dias quando Nós
escolhemos uma nova cidade para morar
não é mesmo
a cada dia é um dia vivido no presente
pois ainda não entramos na memória na
história da terra que os acolheu e olha
Jaraguá foi organizar a sua memória de
cidade quando completou 100 anos em 1976
trazendo o entendimento do seu passado
com a publicação de dois livros contando
a sua história e durante os festejos do
nosso Centenário além da grande
exposição do potencial econômico na
época uma importante exposição Cultural
de memória fotográfica e de objetos do
início da colonização
lançou a semente dos nossos museus e
arquivos históricos de hoje
e o mais incrível
é que há poucos registros fotográficos
dessas comemorações ainda estamos atrás
desta câmera que registrou o evento e
sumiu e olha aí olha aí a importância da
memória visual as festividades do
Centenário ao registrar a nossa história
provocar uma sensação de pertencimento e
orgulho e que afetou positivamente os
caminhos que estavam sendo desenhados
fez toda a diferença na trajetória
evolutiva da cidade como a conhecemos
hoje
agora talvez vocês comecem a compreender
um pouco a minha obsessão pela
importância desta data dos 150 anos
é esta sensação de pertencimento da
época do Centenário buscamos traseiro
Jaraguá ontem hoje construindo histórias
e compreensões de paisagem à nossa volta
aproveitando a memória fotográfica do
passado para comparar com os nossos dias
atuais
Olha uma memória fotográfica que até
pouco tempo atrás era guardado em alguns
caixas de papelão de um mundo físico
palpável e limitado restrito ao negativo
e a sua impressão no papel no entanto
elas passaram a ser eletrônicas abrindo
mais possibilidade de registros ver a
imagem em movimento fitas VHS CD's DVD's
HDs e armazenamento na nuvem Chegamos no
mundo digital onde a profusão margens
deixa as nossas realidades em constante
mutação
e o mundo que seguir em frente a cada
instante a cada novo presente ao mesmo
tempo que se ampliam as possibilidades
de registro tudo fica mais frágil mas
comum banalizado
E esquecemos tudo mais rápido
É mas não estava esquecendo daqueles
versos do início da minha cidade me
desgosto me perdi na identidade dela a
identidade de uma cidade ou região é
feita de pessoas e suas histórias e sua
paisagem que se transforma continuamente
da natureza que a cerca como
documentarista comecei a procurar a
resposta para essas questões e
desconforto pessoal saindo para as ruas
com a câmera junto com a minha equipe
entrevistando centenas de pessoas
tentando entender o que elas mais
gostavam ou não gostavam tanto esse eram
felizes na terra que tinha escolhido
para viver e construir os seus sonhos
comecei a produzir o documentário
Jaraguá 2010 E agora voltei duas décadas
no tempo durante o ano de 1991 quando a
cidade preocupada com seu crescimento
desordenado
parou para se perceber e se debruçou na
sua história tentando antever uma
Jaraguá 20 sim mas era agora em 2010 mas
sustentável equilibrado
esse olhar mais atento a presente dentro
da compreensão compreensão do passado EA
visualização de futuros gerou uma
consciência coletiva
transformadora nas pessoas que
participaram do projeto e fez toda a
diferença na década seguinte nos
caminhos evolutivos da nossa região aqui
temos um belo exemplo de como se
trabalhar o futuro no presente depois
disso vieram outros projetos dessa
natureza
olhar com coragem o passado e de seguir
caminhos isto vale para as nossas vidas
pessoais também
e montando as pessoas que entrevistei
com raríssimas exceções todas estavam
felizes de estar vivendo nesta cidade a
região que escolher para morar
e continuei com o certo desgosto EA
busca por respostas continuou então
todos esses Iva e que produziu até o
momento mais de 1.100 diárias de
gravação terabytes de imagens arquivos
produtos finalizados de memórias visuais
da nossa cidade e região
eu falei um dilema O que fazer com todo
esse material
em qual o sentido de tudo isto
se o resultado das memórias construídas
não conseguir chegar nas pessoas e fazer
parte da vida delas interagir de alguma
maneira realmente tudo isso não tem
sentido o projeto Jaraguá 2026 é uma
série de pequenos documentários trazendo
entendimentos da nossa história nossas
realidades e caminhos futuros
estimulando a consciência cidadã e que
está sendo utilizado hoje nas escolas e
disponibilizado através das redes
sociais buscando inspirar a construção
de uma memória coletiva mais rica e
interessante
a ser a época
2010 era uma data tão distante e passou
muito rápido
assim como nós seu relógio aqui
2026 estranho trazendo a questão
e como iremos comemorar os 150 anos da
região e forma que a data fique marcada
e que foi Como assim como foi a época do
Centenário
e qual o tipo de presente que nós
podemos nos dar a nossa cidade
cada um de nós fazendo a sua parte por
mais simples que seja
olhamos com carinho a nossa história
pessoal e procuremos integrá-la na
história da nossa cidade
a minha parte eu vou procurar Continuar
fazer que já estou realizando gerar
conteúdos reflexivos com o desafio de
organizar e disponibilizar o acesso
amplo
um pouco adianta conservarmos edifícios
antigos
paisagens interessantes
guardarmos fotos e vídeos se elas não
estiverem acessíveis fazendo parte da
nossa vida
e hoje estamos comemorando
145 anos
E ontem eu amanheci
com o seguinte verso que veio de forma
espontânea
é da minha cidade eu gosto e me orgulho
Pois me envolvi na bonita identidade
dela na sua história que está sendo
construída
percebendo melhor a natureza à sua volta
e as pessoas que aqui escolheram para
morar
e por isso temos um caminho a percorrer
nos juntos nos próximos
1825 dias
quem 2026 além de um bolo de 150 Kg ou
150 metros e muita alegria
o andar no espírito a nossa região
a paisagem Urbana nos conte histórias os
morros e rios estejam acessíveis a
natureza nossa volta
surgem memórias ancestrais e
inspiradoras e que sejamos todos
envolvidos pela poesia
Como é bom estar aqui
eu e mais
sentimos que fazemos parte
desta linda história
é muito obrigado
G1
[Aplausos]
E aí